hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the ten reasons why your
belly might not be shrinking on a
ketogenic plan okay now it would be nice
just to give you a simple plan that you
can do and it would work 100% of the
time but each body is different and
there are very specific reasons why you
might not be losing your belly okay
let's start with number one not doing it
correctly so many people that I talked
to I listen to what they're doing and
they're they haven't read the book
they're kind of just they saw a video
and they're just trying it halfway and
they're doing it partially they're not
doing it correctly so you want to bring
your carbs down to 20 grams per day
maybe even less okay if your metabolism
is really slow and you're going through
menopause and you've done many diets in
the past you're going to probably your
carbs down to 10 grams per day that's
just what it's going to take because we
have to counter that slow metabolism a
protein have a moderate amount of
protein between three and six ounces per
day large quantities of vegetables and
as far as the fat in the very beginning
you're going to consume more fat to
allow yourself to go from one meal to
the next but as you start getting into
it you have to cut that fat back because
what we don't want is your body to turn
the dietary fat in the ketones and not
your own body fat into ketones we want
to rely on your own body fat so we want
to cut that down I have a ton of videos
on that I'll put some links down below
so this is number one number two you're
not doing in a minute fasting you're
only doing keto well that's not going to
work because every time you eat you
trigger insulin and so by doing in a min
fasting you can greatly accelerate the
results and decrease insulin big-time so
the combination is really essential
there are so many therapeutic reasons
why you need to do going to fasting but
that's in another video so we want to
combine these two you want to start up
three meals and then slowly do two meals
okay by pushing your breakfast forward
to the point where you're not hungry in
the morning and then you want to take
your dinner in your lunch and squish
them together that would be the ideal
scene to the point where you may want to
go to one meal it
if your metabolism is really slow and or
if you have a slow thyroid okay it's
just what you're gonna have to do at
this point number three it is working
and you might think it's not working
okay now in the beginning of the program
a lot of people lose a lot of weight and
then all of a sudden they slow down the
weight loss and they think it's not
working there used to like a pound a day
and now they go a pound a week and they
think it's not working they get
frustrated on a real healthy person the
most you can lose is two pounds a week
I'm sorry but that's just the fact on an
average person it could be one pound a
week it's still working it's just gonna
take some time so the goal is to get
healthy then lose the weight so what I
would recommend is focus on the other
indicators like energy tolerance for
sleep memory focus inflammation focus on
those not just the weight loss okay but
if you're losing even a half a pound a
week its whoo it's working but it's it's
a little slower but we can always speed
it up but the point is that don't give
up if you're only losing a half a pound
or a pound a week just tweak things
number four if you have a fat liver the
capacity to make ketones the the
capacity to make growth hormone work is
going to be less and the capacity to rid
the fats going to be less so you're
gonna have to improve this fatty liver I
have a video down below on how to do
that you need you need to get some
choline that's a type of B vitamin it
strips off out of the liver and it'll
help you the other point about this is
that if your stomach is large your body
will have to get rid of the fat in the
liver before the fat underneath here in
your abdomen area so even though your
abdomen might not be shrinking your body
is still losing fat but it has to get
get it out of the organs first before it
gets rid of the superficial or the fat
that's right underneath your abdomen so
that's just a point I want to bring up
because it's very very common so the
body will go off to the liver first and
the organs and then
the other fat second number five you're
gaining muscle mass if you're female and
you're menopausal chances are you have a
lot of atrophy
that's loss of muscle it looks just like
fat but it's atrophy one way to know
that is if you're sitting in a chair and
you get up and it takes you a lot of
work to get up because your quadricep
your your thigh muscles are weak you
have atrophy so you're gonna have to
gain the muscle back while you're doing
in a minute fasting in keto and in the
process muscle by volume weighs more
than fat so you might find no loss of
midsection yet you're getting stronger
the point I wanna make is that it takes
a really healthy diet for a good year or
two to get these muscles back with
exercise so it's not going to happen
in a week or two so go for the long haul
I know it's frustrating but that's just
the facts of what's going to happen but
you will eventually get it back because
atrophy is a is a pretty serious problem
it's not a little thing it's like your
muscles are basically gone okay number
six you're not exercising correctly or
you're not exercising at all exercise is
not the big tool to help you lose weight
but it can really help increase growth
hormone toning and a little bit of
weight loss okay so this is important
high intensity low duration short little
bursts of high-intensity full-body
exercise is the best I mean if you can
do sprinting that would be the ideal
scene but some people they don't have
good knees so they have to get in the
bike the spin bike and start doing that
for a while
elliptical but for a lot of people you
have to just start just walking that's
their first first step so do what you
can gradually work up to it number seven
if you bloat from the vegetables that
you're not used to consuming or too much
fat or whatever because you don't have
enough stomach acid or enough bile from
the gallbladder that can make your
stomach stay big when I was in practice
there were people that actually had food
allergies that kept them bloating
there are people that are doing kale
that they were just bloated week after
week they didn't connect the dots that
they can't digest those foods they
developed constipation well how you
gonna lose weight if you have
constipation so we want to have you
consume foods that you can digest so
regular lettuce green lettuce is
probably easier to digest than spinach
or other vegetables so modify the type
of vegetables that you consume and make
sure you have no bloating maybe you need
some help with apple cider vinegar
pertain how to chloride some gallbladder
support all right number eight other
health problems so let's say you have a
thyroid issue let's say you have some
other hormonal issue you have hot
flashes you have a heart condition
these other health problems can inhibit
your ability to lose weight because as
you get healthy sometimes the body will
focus on other problems first before
losing the weight so what I like to do
is I like to get rid of all the weak
links in your body bless so let's say
for example you're trying to lose weight
it's not working well what is the
weakest link in your body is it the
thyroid is it the adrenals focus on that
then watch what happens to the weight
because it's all about getting healthy
then losing the weight all right number
nine medications lots of medications
from cholesterol medication statins -
antidepressant medications have a little
side effects of preventing weight loss
in fact a lot of the symptoms from these
medications are you develop more insulin
resistance which increases more insulin
well you're going to have to get with
your doctor to find an alternative
something natural maybe that you can
work with but that's between you and
your doctor because the medication is
just going to be a barrier it's going to
keep things really slow and one more
point about medications if your blood
values are normal and the doctor still
has you on medications then find another
doctor because you don't want to take
medications if you really don't need
them alright number 10
stress and lack of sleep can severely
inhibit your ability to lose your belly
so I have tons of videos on techniques
that you can do things you can do food
you can eat
nutrition you can take to reduce stress
usually supporting a healthy adrenal
gland to enhance the sleep which will
then actually greatly help you lose
weight I mean there are people that all
we did is fix their sleep and they
started losing weight not changing their
diet not doing anything else and they
continue to exercise all we did is tweak
the sleep improve it a little bit and
all of a sudden that was to the point
where they start losing weight so it's
quite amazing all right guys there you
have it to find out which ones apply and
go ahead and focus on that and thanks
for watching
hey guys I had a quick question I'm
thinking about doing a keto summit in
Washington do you see this fall and the
reason I want to do in the fall that's
my favorite time of the year where the
leaves are falling it's going to be
gorgeous in Washington DC and I wanted
to know if you would be interested in
coming out so this will have a chance to
meet you and cover the entire subject of
keto and in a minute fasting so I
haven't formulated all the details yet
but I just wanted to find out if you'd
be interested I put a link down below
let me know